it's the question everyone wants to know
where does julia fox stand with kanye
west as he publicly attempts to win kim
kardashian back well a source tells e.t
quote kanye and julia are still dating
but they are not a traditional couple
kanye is still obsessed with getting his
family back together but julia is his
primary girl right now adding quote that
julia isn't worried about kanye and kim
getting back together and is just
enjoying the ride and taking it all in
i call him my boyfriend and he calls me
his girlfriend this comes after the
actress shared her thoughts on kanye's
public comments toward kim in the latest
episode of the call her daddy podcast
with host alex cooper i'm sure there's
still some sort of residual feelings and
it's like it's normal it's human you
know but
i also like
know that he's with me now so
and that's all that matters on wednesday
kanye made his most recent public
attempt to get the keeping up star back
he shared photos of kim and their kids
from inside her march vogue cover shoot
on instagram and captioned it quote god
please bring our family back together
you just gotta roll with it speaking of
kim's vogue spread the reality star
opened up to the magazine about the
epiphany that she says caused her to
divorce from yay the mama force says
that for so long she did what made other
people happy but in the last two years
she decided to put herself first
why not saying quote that feels really
good and even if that created changes
and caused my divorce i think it's
important to be honest with yourself
about what really makes you happy i've
chosen myself i think it's okay to
choose you
it is what it is kim filed for divorce
from the grammy winner last year after
six years of marriage and as for
co-parenting their four children north
saint chicago and psalm kim says it's
all about keeping it positive telling
the magazine quote you could be so hurt
or angry at your ex but i think in front
of the kids it always has to be your
dad's the best make sure you are your
co-parents biggest cheerleader no matter
what you're personally going through
that echoes what kim's sister chloe told
et back in 2019 about the good example
their own parents said after divorcing
it's hard work for all parties i think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
[Music]
you